- This line wraps around three times
before it starts going straight.
- [Narrator] If you've traveled recently
you've likely seen long lines
and stranded passengers.
- Airports will definitely
be significantly busier
than summer of 2021.
- [Narrator] Inflation is
also pumping up the price
of everything from food
to flights, to gas.
So to help you save money and time,
Wall Street Journal Travel
Columnist, Dawn Gilbertson
has three tips to help you
navigate this busy travel season.
Number one, plan ahead to save time
and alleviate stress at the airport.
- One option, a lot of flyers
don't seem to be aware of yet
is a relatively new program
that allows you to reserve
a spot in the security line for free.
- [Narrator] This program is
offered at several airports,
including those in Seattle, Los Angeles,
and Newark New Jersey.
Each airport has its own protocols
but generally travelers
can sign up for 15 minutes
security appointments up to
72 hours before their flights.
Once at the airport, you show a QR code
and enter designated
checkpoint lanes that take you
to the front of the general security line.
- The Phoenix Airport, for
example, told me that people
who have used that line
on average report saving
at least 20 minutes in
the security checkpoint
- [Narrator] TSA pre-check
and Clear can also save time
but they charge membership fees.
Another time saving option,
a relatively new feature at
airport Starbucks locations.
- You can now do mobile
ordering at the airport
and anybody who's seen a
Starbucks line at a major airport
or even a smaller airport, you know,
knows sometimes they can rival the lines
at the TSA checkpoint
- Use the Starbucks mobile
app to skip the line
and place your order.
I placed my order at 5:08
and I received my coffee at 5:14.
- [Narrator] And for those renting cars,
you can also take advantage
of line skipping options
by signing up for rental
agencies loyalty programs.
Tip number two, if something goes wrong
like your flight gets
canceled, act quickly.
- Don't just do one thing.
You know, if you're
gonna go get in that line
while you're in that line, get
on the airlines mobile app.
Look at other options at the airport.
- [Narrator] United Airlines, for example
has a new tool called, Agent on Demand,
which connects travelers
with customer service agents
in other cities as a way to
speed up the rebooking process.
- I'm also a very big fan
of reaching out to airlines
on Twitter, direct message.
They tend to get back to you quicker.
You start the conversation
about rebooking.
- [Narrator] Another
thing to keep in mind is,
if an airline cancels your flight
and gives you your money back,
that refund might not cover
the cost of a new flight this summer.
- Do not ask for that refund, you know
so that you can book on another airline
until you shop another
airline because that flight
could be three times
the price that you paid.
So this summer, in a lot of cases
you have to weigh the
airlines rebooking option.
- [Narrator] Finally, shop around.
- If you haven't booked
your airline tickets yet,
maybe check out some of the newer airlines
that have launched during the pandemic.
A couple that come to mind
are Avelo and Breeze Airways.
Since not everybody has heard of them
you might have a better
chance at seat availability.
- [Narrator] Both airlines
follow the model of discounters
like Allegiant and Frontier.
Avelo operates flights out
of new Haven, Los Angeles
and Orlando.
And Breeze Airways focuses on
mid-size cities like Hartford,
Connecticut, and
Charleston, South Carolina.
- Check their websites
because a lot of times
the tickets are significantly cheaper.
Both airlines have relatively new planes,
experienced executives, and
some routes you can fly nonstop
and skip the connecting airport drama.
- [Narrator] But keep in mind
that these smaller airlines
might not have as many flight options.
- On most routes, they
don't fly every single day.
So, you know, in times of flight troubles
you might not be able to get
out as quickly as you want.
- [Narrator] If you're going
on a road trip you might
be able to save money on
gas by using the same tools
you use at home.
- If you have a Costco
membership, you know
Walmart also has a membership program.
You know, you can use
those savings on the road.
GasBuddy is one of the apps
that a lot of people download
before a trip, it'll find
the lowest gas in your area.
- [Narrator] But
regardless of where or how
you plan to travel this summer.
- Have a backup plan, maybe
a couple backup plans.
You know, we've all seen
the headlines on the number
of canceled flights and delayed flights.
So just look at your
options before you take off.